et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
laurence alain bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous député du val
de marne rapporteur général du budget
vous êtes le candidat de la majorité
présidentielle aux régionales en île de
france et on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale bonjour pascal jalabert du
groupe ebra les journaux régionaux de
l'est de la france
on va bien sûr parlé longuement des
régionales laurent saint martin mais
d'abord l'actualité l'actualité c'est la
réforme des retraites la priorité ce
sont les retraites c'est ce qu'a dit
hier bruno le maire dans le journal du
dimanche sauf que ça fait des semaines
voire des mois qu'on entend cette petite
musique au gouvernement que les
retraites sont une priorité pourquoi ne
pas passer des paroles aux actes et
relancer cette réforme
l'actualité ce n'est pas la réforme des
retraites l'actualité c'est la poursuite
du quoi qu'il en coûte c'est le plan de
relance c'est de faire en sorte que
notre économie qui a si bien résisté
pendant cette crise grâce aux mesures
exceptionnelles que nous avons mis en
place puisse redémarrer alors confirmant
de faillites d'entreprises qu'il n'y ait
pas de perte d'emploi dans la mesure de
ce que nous pourrons faire dans cette
reprise économique ce qui est vrai c'est
que à deux ans trois ans dix ans vingt
ans nous devons déjà préempté ce débat
de savoir comment nous allons équilibrer
notre modèle social et ce de façon tout
à fait transversale c'est vrai pour les
retraites c'est vrai pour l'assurance
maladie
c'est vrai pour l'assurance chômage et
cela passera de toute façon par le
besoin de mettre en place des réformes
structurelles et le cas des retraites et
en cas comme les autres c'est juste
qu'il est souvent plus médiatisé et
qu'on aime bien en parler autour d'un
plateau mais c'est vrai qu'il faut
amarré dans l'autre parce qu'elle est
nécessaire de fait le calendrier
appartient au président de la république
est ce que ce sera avant après
l'élection présidentielle ça moi je ne
sais pas vous le dire ce matin c'est une
décision du président moi je pense que
les trajectoires d' équilibre des
finances publiques en tant que
rapporteur général du budget doivent
être le plus tôt possible tant que si
nous pouvons faire des trajectoires de
finances publiques avec des mesures qui
permettraient s'avérer à terme
l'équilibré de nos retraites
alors je pense effectivement
c'est avant l'élection et ses quelque
peu le mesure c'est le big bang qui
était promis ou alors c'est juste
allonger les trimestres où l'âge légal
de départ
en fait je pense que c'est quand je
pense qu'une réforme systémique de notre
régime de nos régimes de retraite
d'ailleurs tout le sujet n'est pas
possible ni en temps parlementaire ni en
temps de dialogue social que cela
demande d'ici l'élection présidentielle
en revanche trouver des murs et le
résidentiel on oublie la retraite à
points je pense qu'effectivement le
calendrier ne permet pas en revanche
s'il y avait une volonté du président de
la république de trouver des mesures
pour mieux équilibrer nos comptes parce
que je le rappelle nous avons et nous
sommes le seul pays à avoir des
retraites qui pèse pour 14 % de notre
richesse nationale alors moi je serais
prêt à le défendre dès cet automne si
cela venait à être le choix du président
de la république
après c'est une décision qui lui
appartient clairement dire aux français
va faire travailler plus pascal et bruno
le maire y dit un volume global de
travail plus important mediapad ne pas
être ne pas être plus clair et dire
qu'on a laissé travailler plus il va
faire travailler plus longtemps surtout
pour connaissez ce débat il ya
effectivement l'âge de départ à la
retraite il y a le nombre d'années de
cotisations il ya aussi tout un nombre
de variables qui peuvent aussi permettre
un meilleur équilibrage
ce qui est sûr c'est que dans notre pays
on ne parvient pas à équilibrer notre
système de retraite il faut dire aux
français qu'après la crise
si nous ne parvenons pas à équilibrer
nos finances publiques qu'on appelle
structurelles on ne sera plus en mesure
à terme à cause de notre niveau
d'endettement est bien de faire face aux
crises exceptionnels comme nous avons pu
le faire pendant la crise que vit 19
c'est ça le contrat qu'il faut passer
avec le pays si vous voulez un état fort
qui sache vous protéger en temps de
crise alors une fois un état qui sache
aussi équilibrer ses comptes
on va dire en temps normal donc
s'attaque à l équilibre du système à
l'automne pour oui pour moi je pense que
le plus tôt le mieux on va parler du
budget rectificatif qui était examinée
par les députés cette semaine en
commission et vendredi en séance budget
rectificatif de 20 milliards dont 15
milliards et demi pour aider les
secteurs en difficulté l'hôtellerie le
tourisme la restauration
ce sera le dernier train de mesures du
quoi qu'il en coûte en tout cas c'est la
poursuite de mesures exceptionnelles que
les gens connaissent maintenant assez
bien le fonds de solidarité
l'activité partielle les prêts garantis
par l'état certaines annulations de
charges bref tout ce qui
allège la trésorerie de nos entreprises
et particulièrement de tpe nos pme et
qui permettent finalement de maintenir
le niveau d'emplois dans notre pays nous
remettons des crédits budgétaires pour
s'assurer que la sortie du quoi qu'il en
coûte se fasse bien de façon progressive
et que dans cette période là l'état soit
toujours en soutien des entreprises de
manière générale mais spécifiquement des
secteurs qui eux sont toujours le plus
freiné par la structure est longée
précisément il m'a encore derrière parce
que la rentrée s'annonce quand même
difficile il peut y avoir des
revendications salariales de la part des
stars
tout ce que nous faisons depuis un an
c'est du cousu main la gestion d'une
crise comme celle du colis de 19 et du
cousu main pourquoi du cousu main les
secteurs ne vivent pas la crise de la
même manière vous avez quelques secteurs
ils sont rares qui ont même bénéficié de
la situation pour faire plus de chiffre
d'affaires vous avez quelques secteurs
et c'est la grande majorité qu'ils ont
pu bon an mal an poursuivre leur
activité économique
grâce aux aides et qu'ils ont plus
justement maintenir leur niveau de
trésorerie et d'emploi et puis vous avez
certains secteurs qui sont grandes
souffrances
je pense aux sous traitants de
l'aéronautique je pense à ça tu as
secteur automobile je pense au tourisme
je pense à l'événementiel je pense
évidemment à nos quartiers à nos
restaurateurs qui ont tant souffert de
leur fermeture pendant tant de mois et
donc ces secteurs dits prioritaires vous
savez ces fameuses listes s1 est ce que
nous avons tant débattue pendant ces
derniers mois et bien faut continuer à
les accompagner temps qu'il faudra sur
ces secteurs là moi je suis partisan du
quoi qu'il en coûte temps qu'il faudra
ce qui compte c'est qu'en parallèle de
ceux là eh bien nous mettions les
investissements nécessaires pour
investir
ça c'est le plan de relance 100
milliards d'euros ont été mis sur la
table nous dès qu'ils sont à bon rythme
et les entreprises redémarrent ce qu'il
faut c'est que le quoi qu'il en coûte
ne sois pas si vous voulez uniquement la
phase estivale pour les prochaines
semaines mais il faut que le quoi qu'il
en coûte soit en parallèle d'un grand
plan de relance et d'investissement
parce que nous ne parviendrons pas à
avoir cinq six points de croissance à la
fin de l'année si nos entreprises
n'investissent pas mais ça tombe bien en
un pays en à une économie qui a déjà
démontré d'ailleurs l'an dernier l'été
dernier souvenez-vous
si du point de croissance en un pays qui
est fort en un pays des entreprises qui
savent rebondir et on a déjà la risée on
invitera si on peut tout miser sur la
croissance laurencin matin est-ce qu'il
va falloir un second plan de relance
pour redynamiser l'économie
depuis le début de cette crise j'ai un
discours très cohérent là-dessus tout ce
qui est bon pour l'investissement et la
croissance est à prendre
nous avons un plan de relance qui est
déjà inégalée dans l'histoire mais
quatre fois supérieur au plan de relance
de la crise de 2008
il est supérieur à beaucoup d'autres
pays européens
si demain nous devions faire des
investissements complémentaires
notamment dans les nouvelles
trajectoires économiques c'est-à-dire la
transition écologique plus de
compétitivité
les nouvelles technologies
personnellement je serais favorable à
poursuivre l'endettement pour de
l'investissement utile c'est-à-dire de
l'investissement créateur d'emploi
créateurs de valeur et qu'ils soient
demain les conditions de la prospérité
retrouvée dans notre pays j'avais
proposé avec pascal canfin bénédicte
pérol notamment que nous puissions
investir ou davantage dans tout ce qui
nous permettra d'atteindre nos objectifs
en termes de transition écologique
nous avions proposé sur le long terme
pas sur seulement les deux prochaines
années de l'investissement
complémentaire à hauteur de 70 milliards
d'euros pour que nous puissions
atteindre nos objectifs
c'est le moment nous sommes dans une
période d'emprunts à taux très bas
nous sommes dans une période où il faut
investir pour se relever et donc c'est
une période une fenêtre de tir si vous
voulez qu'il ne faut pas en déficit et
record une dette record a quasiment son
impression du pib pour le moment on
oublie les règles budgétaires pour vous
c'est pas le moment tous les pays
enregistrent des déficits records
pendant cette crise la france n'est
évidemment pas isolé et même faut-il le
dire ne s'en sort pas si mal quand on
compare à beaucoup d'autres pays
là dessus ce qu'il faut c'est que cet
endettement ce déficit exceptionnel
aujourd'hui que nous vivons puisse être
demain stabiliser puis réduit notamment
grâce à la croissance
la notion d'investissement est
importante je m'endette aujourd'hui pour
produire de la croissance qui elle-même
sera non seulement le facteur de
remboursement de la dette
mais surtout le facteur d'emplois le
facteur de prospérité dans notre pays un
dernier mot là dessus puisque hier dans
le genre
dimanche les députés les républicains
ont présenté un plan pour la relance
économique et durable via notamment une
baisse de 30 milliards d impôt de
production pour les ramener dans la
moyenne européenne 10 style et graver
dans la constitution une règle d'or de
stabilité fiscale fixant un seuil
minimal d'impôts des entreprises est ce
que vous approuvez sa magie je remarque
surtout que quand nous avons proposé la
baisse des impôts de production dans le
plan de relance que nous faisons à
hauteur de 20 milliards d'euros
la majorité des députés aient l'air nous
reprocher cette baisse des impôts de
production puisque souvenez-vous les
collectivités locales
n'allez plus avoir la fiscalité
économiques directes et que cela
passerait par de la compensation
budgétaire de l'état donc je remarque
que ceux qui n'étaient pas acceptables
il ya quelques mois devient aujourd'hui
leurs priorités économiques
après tout on peut tout changer d'avis
quand c'est pour aller dans le bon sens
moi je le salue donc ça ça va dans le
bon sens et la base d'un cours de
production
c'est nous qui l'avons proposé depuis
plus d'un an donc je serais assez pour
vous dire que ce serait les règles d'or
peuvent être des bonnes idées d'ailleurs
avec eric woerth député l heure nous
allons proposer une proposition de loi
organique au mois de juillet pour que
justement la stabilité dans un premier
temps et puis surtout la réduction de
nos déficits par une règle d'or et
notamment par la maîtrise de nos comptes
de fonctionnement le solde structurel
effectivement puisse être inscrite de
façon organique et pourquoi pas demain
de façon constitutionnelle la
procréation médicale assistée pour tout
don que revient l'assemblée nationale
quel type de débat vous attendez je
l'espère le plus serein possible parce
que d'en douter non parce que ce qu'il
compte dans l'examen des lois de
bioéthique
c'est que chacun puisse donner son avis
que tout avis soient respectés j'insiste
surtout ta vie soit respectée et qu'à la
fin la majorité délibère ça vous paraît
évident pour vous me connaissez bien le
parlement et je vous assure que le
nombre de lois cela nécessite de le
rappeler et donc il faut d'abord débat
apaisé
nous avons eu deux lectures précédente
plus tôt
respectueuse de la vie de chacun je
trouve souvenez-vous il ya quelques
années des débats pour le mariage pour
tous était beaucoup plus douloureux est
beaucoup plus difficile
là vous avez des opinions qui sont très
défavorables à la pma pour toutes
moi je fais partie de ceux qui pensent
avec ma majorité que c'est une avancée
sociétale considérable pour toutes les
femmes qui vont pouvoir en bénéficier
demain et je suis extrêmement fier que
dès cet été après la promulgation de la
loi
nous pourrons enfin en france permettre
à toutes les femmes d'avoir accès à la
pma légalement et bien moi ça vous savez
quand on dit que parfois la majorité
présidentielle n'a pas fait de réformes
que la majorité présidentielle n'a pas
fait avancer le pays
mais personne n'avait fait ça personne
n'avait dû lutter pour l'égalité des
droits de cette façon là pour l'égalité
des droits de toutes les femmes
et bien moi je suis extrêmement fier et
je souhaite que dès cet après-midi dans
l'hémicycle les débats puissent se
retrouver de façon apaisée et que nous
puissions voter cette disposition
on va parler des régionales laurent
saint martin puisque vous êtes le
candidat de la majorité présidentielle
aux régionales en ile-de-france alors
d'abord un mot sur les sondages ce sont
des sondages on est d'accord mais dans
les sondages ou fait deux fois moins que
valérie pécresse qui est donné largement
en tête pour le moment est-ce que du
coup vous jouer le match pour la
deuxième place
alors moi je quand je rentre sur un
terrain c'est pour gagner vous
m'excuserez peut-être d'être assez
simple là dessus mais je suis rugbyman
quand je rentre sur un terrain c'est
pour gagner pas pour autre chose
donc les sondages tout le monde les
regarde moi j'ai un programme 154
propositions qui sont toutes très
concrète tout chiffré le rapporteur
général du budget ne se permettrait pas
de faire un programme non chiffrée mais
surtout c'est un programme qui répond à
une grande problématique dans notre
région qui est qu un francilien sur deux
aspirent à quitter la région
c'est pas acceptable on a au lendemain
d'une crise sans précédent que des
enjeux d'emplois considérable un risque
de casse sociale considérable si la
région qui a la compétence du
développement économique et à la
compétence de la formation
professionnelle ne met pas davantage de
moyens ne met pas davantage de vision
dans l'avenir économique social
territorial de son territoire alors je
pense effectivement que la région peut
continuer à décliner et surtout que
cette aspiration à quitter
l'ile-de-france se poursuivre moi je
veux redonner envie d'île de france
c'est un
au projet c'est un projet optimiste
positif pour les franciliennes et les
franciliens pour les six prochaines
années
et puis surtout je suis le seul candidat
pardon à vouloir vraiment être président
de la région à vouloir l'être pour les
six prochaines années
je ne suis pas candidat à autre chose et
je ne réfléchis pas à 2022 et quand je
dis ça je ne cible pas particulièrement
madame pécresse je remarque que tous les
candidats non constate emmanuel macron
et la présidentielle donc vous me posez
la question de pourquoi j'y vais pour
quelle place j'y vais j'y vais pour la
première fois c'est à dire le candidat
german bardella pour l'assemblée
nationale et candidat de gauche qui ne
veulent pas être président de ces choses
que vous avez entendu
est ce que vous avez entendu monsieur
bardella parler de l'élection régionale
il a dit que c'était un apéritif pour
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22 je
reprends ses termes un apéritif
mais quel mépris pour les électeurs quel
mépris vous avez la première région de
france l'une des plus puissantes régions
économiques d'europe et l'élection de
l'exécutif qui viendrait prendre les
décisions pour le développement
économique pour les transports en commun
pour les lycées pour la formation
ce sera un apéritif et bien moi je suis
candidat justement pour lutter contre
cet oubli que les élections locales
intermédiaires sont fondamentales pour
l'avenir de nos territoires sont
fondamentales pour lutter contre les
fractures territoriales en à la région
la plus jeune la plus riche mais aussi
la plus inégalitaire qui propose des
solutions concrètes pour résorber ses
idéaux ce n'est pas le signe finalement
que les électeurs feront signant lui
font confiance je trouve qu'elle a un
bon bilan et on vit dû redonner la
région je ne vous apprends rien en
disant qu'il ya toujours une prime aux
sortants dans ces élections là bien à
partir de ce moment là ses projets quand
en sortant ne sont pas en tête dans les
projets qu à regarder mais pratiquement
je pense ce qui compte ce projet contre
projet vous savez à l'heure où on se
parle les franciliens commence à voir
les professions de foi les programmes
dans leur boîte à lettres
il regarde il regarde et c'est sur la
dernière ligne droite souvent dans les
dix derniers jours que vraiment
l'appétence aux élections locales
arrivent et monte
et bien moi je fais le pari que par les
propositions que la liste envie
d'ile-de-france que je conduis men et
bien ces propositions la triumph le 20
et 27 juin
parce que ce sont elles qui s'occupe
réellement de l'avenir de france ayant
pour cible
oui justement vous avez dit tout à
l'heure que 1 francilienne sur deux
aspirent à quitter la région
sans entrer dans tous vos crocs
programme quels sont les deux trois
mesures qui peuvent les inciter à rester
ou investir dans cette région d'abord
moi je veux que les franciliens soient
fiers des transilien
je vais vous prendre une mesure je veux
proposer le fonds d épargne populaire le
fonds d'épargné populaire c'est
permettre enfin et c'est la première
fois et ce travail là je le fais depuis
des années la première fois qu'on peut
mettre des citoyens en face de l'avenir
de leur entreprise de leur économie
locale
les pannes qui a été accumulée pendant
sept dernières années est à peu près 40
milliards d'euros en plus lié à la crise
qu vide qui sont dans les comptes en
banque des franciliens je veux qu'elle
soit productif cette épargne et je veux
que la région puisse permettre de créer
un fonds d'investissement dans lequel
les particuliers à investir et et dans
lequel nous pourrions et bien permettre
aux fonds propres de nos pme de grandir
à nos commerçants et à nos artisans de
se développer d'avoir des projets et ça
c'est créer de la fierté locale et c'est
pas à la belle c'est pas un énorme coup
de tampon c'est réel c'est concret c'est
de l'investissement et c'est
l'investissement populaire c'est à dire
que c'est vous qui vous permettait aux
commerçants en bas de chez vous 2
développé et bien ça vous voyez vous
c'est une identité
ça c'est une identité économique et puis
j'ai juste un maul est oui parce qu'hier
dans le journal du dimanche je rendrai
pulvar et présenter ses propositions
économiques et elle veut la création
d'un livret à régional à rémunération
garantie pour mobiliser les parts des
franciliens et la diriger vers des
investissements it in ça ça ressemble un
peu au fond des peuples non c'est très
différent sans rentrer dans la technique
un livret réglementé
c'est un livret que vous êtes obligés de
rémunérer un peu comme le livret a
vous le faites aujourd'hui ça coûte très
cher à la collectivité qui peut par
ailleurs s'endetter sur les marchés
comme je l ai dit tout à l'heure à des
taux extrêmement bas
moi je ne propose pas un livret
réglementé avec un taux dépargne arrêté
je propose aux franciliens de participer
à un fonds d'investissement
et c'est la performance une banque
publique d'investissement les jeunes à
ressasser gré la gestion écologique
existe déjà c'est la banque publique
d'investissement j ai travaillé six ans
donc je peux témoigner que ça existe
déjà
ce qui est sûr c'est que mon fonds
d'épargné populaire
lui l'a sa performance pour ce qui place
l'argent dépendra de la performance des
entreprises
donc c'est beaucoup plus intéressant on
est lié à la performance économique
c'est pas un livret réglementé ce très
différents le vous avez dit je rentre
sur le terrain pour gagner pour gagner
entre les deux tours il faut peut-être
trouver des coéquipiers
alors qui peut qui sauve aux coéquipiers
capables de vous rejoindre ou vous de
les rejoindre avec les écologistes et
les socialistes ou santé compatibles
j'ai 224 coéquipiers et ils sont tous
sur mes listes dans les huit
départements et ils sont issus de
d'horizons très différents
vous avez des membres du gouvernement
vous avez des parlementaires vous avez
des mères vous avez des adjoints au
maire et vous avez et c'est la grande
majorité et j'en suis très fier des
personnes issues de la société civile
des personnes qui n'ont jamais fait de
politique
j'ai le directeur général adjoint de
l'institut gustave roussy stéphane
pardoux qui est sur ma liste dans le val
de marne
excellent pôle de recherche dans la
lutte contre le cancer
j'ai nathalie sonnac sur la liste à
paris universitaires de renom sur les
enjeux culturels et d'information j'ai
beaucoup de personnalité que vous n'avez
jamais vu en politique et c'est normal
et vous les verrez demain grâce à la
majorité présidentielle
je ne travaille qu'avec ses 224
colistiers ce que nous avons construit à
la fois avec ces personnes et à la fois
avec nos idées pour créer nos
propositions j'en suis extrêmement fier
et vous faire monter sur moi pour lille
entre temps sur un terrain de rugby pour
jouer les matchs jusqu'au bout je ne me
pose pas d'autres questions
juste un mot quand même parce que
vous êtes rentré dans cette campagne
début mars mais mars est dans votre
première interview votre première
proposition c'était la police de
sécurité régionale là depuis le début de
l'étape vous nous parlez plus de
sécurité
pourquoi vous avez changé dax dans votre
campagne j'aurais pu et c'est à dire ma
deuxième proposition
suite à votre question de qu'est ce qui
fait que les gens ont envie de quitter
l'île de france est aussi l'insécurité
dans les transports vous avez raison
l'insécurité dans les transports elle
grandit c'est un fait on peut pas s'en
satisfaire elle grandit six ans les
chiffres à l'appui
donc soit on continue comme avant c'est
à dire on demande à l'état on demande à
la sncf on demande à la ratp on finance
quand on est la région des forces de
sécurité complémentaires soit on change
de braquet
soit on change de braquet et on trouve
une nouvelle solution plus efficace
cette nouvelle solution c'est ce que je
propose c'est la police régionale des
transports
la police régionale des transports ça
veut dire que ile-de-france mobilité qui
est l'autorité organisatrice de mobilité
doit se doter en son sein d'un service
interne de sécurité complémentaires mais
surtout surtout qui a la responsabilité
de coordonner l'action de toutes les
autres forces de sécurité au côté de la
préfecture de police
il manque aujourd'hui même pas un moyen
de pallier les manquements de l'état sur
cette question de sécurité mais l'état
fait son travail nous avons recruté sur
la plaque de la préfecture de police
plus de 1600 agents complémentaire
pendant que la majorité sous nicolas
sarkozy gouvernement de françois fillon
valérie pécresse ministre du budget en
avait supprimé 12 milles à l'échelle
nationale rendez vous compte du travail
que nous devons faire et là encore c'est
le rapporteur du budget qui vous le dit
pour récupérer pour rattraper tout ces
baisses de fonctionnaires de police et
de gendarmerie donc l'état fait son
travail de rattrapage
c'est en cours et nous aurons à la fin
du mandat recruté dix mille
fonctionnaires de police et de
gendarmerie
la sncf et la ratp font aussi leur
travail moi je veux que la région a la
compétence des transports en commun donc
doit assurer la sécurité et la
tranquillité de ses usagers c'est aussi
simple que cela
donc un service interne de sécurité à
idées est faible et la responsabilité de
mieux coordonner l'ensemble du travail
qui est fait et vous savez là dessus
faut pas faire de mauvaise polémique
je crois volontiers dans la sincérité de
madame pécresse qu'elle veut faire mieux
sur la sécurité dans les transports mais
le résultat n'est pas là le résultat
n'est pas là c'est donc il ne faut pas
continuer à faire comme avant
ça veut dire qu'il faut faire autrement
et proposer des nouvelles solutions un
dernier mot sur un sujet qui n'a rien à
voir avec l'art et les régionales de
france mais c'est cette phrase de jean
luc mélenchon et hier jean luc mélenchon
il a prédit un grave incident dans la
dernière semaine de la campagne
présidentielle en 2022 pour montrer du
doigt les musulmans pour les stigmatiser
il dit c'est déjà écrit qu'est ce que
vous pensez de cette phrase je la trouve
gravissime
je trouve la phrase de jean luc
mélenchon gravissime la france insoumise
et jean luc mélenchon avait déjà franchi
un certain nombre de lignes jaunes
républicaine depuis ces derniers mois
je crois que là on a franchi une ligne
écarlate dans les valeurs de la
république
si du complotisme c'est du complotisme
veut dire qu'il est sorti du champ
républicain pour vous quand vous faites
preuve de complotisme et que vous
laisser penser qu'il y aurait des
attentats orchestrés à quelques jours
des élections présidentielles c'est
honteux c'est scandaleux c'est très
dangereux pour la démocratie
c'est très dangereux pour la démocratie
et jean luc mélenchon était un
républicain
il nous a démontré depuis plusieurs mois
depuis plusieurs semaines qu'il sent les
eaux dû s'en éloigner
il en est définitivement sorti de
lui-même here
merci beaucoup à face à martin d'avoir
été notre invité pour des raisons
d'équité comme cette tête de liste on va
regarder ensemble la liste de vos
concurrents lors de ces régionales en
île de france et je rappelle bien sûr à
tous nos téléspectateurs comme chaque
jour que l'élection aura lieu les 20 et
27 juin prochain merci beaucoup
certains d'avoir été notre invité pascal
vous restez avec nous puisqu'on place
tout de suite au club des territoires on
va parler des régionales
[Musique]